hello everyone
so this is sherba uh uh echo server
uh i'm manager of sustainability uh
communication team with first retaining
group
sorry so i don't know why i can't okay i
can start my video
now again
hello everyone so thank you so much for
your time today
so this is such a great opportunity to
talk about
our sustainability let me
introduce by myself at first i joined
the company
in 2002 and since the establishment of
social contribution department
which is a former department department
name of sustainability i have been
working for
implementation of sustainability several
actions
all product recycling tohoku
deconstruction support
project which was affected by tohoku
earthquake in 2011 and grameen uniqlo
which is a social business in bangladesh
to solve the
poverty issue from 2009
so my current responsibility is
dissemination for sustainability
information in store digital media and
so on
so today so uh we have several
sustainability activation uh such as
environmental things uh human rights
issue and diversity and inclusion and
uh social contribution things so mainly
today
uh we want to talk about uh
about environmental pillar so we want to
especially we want to focus on product
uh
like uh environmental friendly
uh product so because
so there are a lot of audience who are
working in
uh design industry thank you and also i
want to
uh uh introduce my colleague another boy
hello everybody my name is
director of men's altar bottoms
and chats in unicorn join joined
uniquely
as a new graduate in 2001
studied my career as a store staff store
manager
and supervisor since 2009
in charge of merchandising my main
responsibility
is all about product from
planning to the delivery currently my
passion is to bring sustainability
in all that process we have
two big projects and we will get to them
later
do you know uniqlo we are the company
selling not just the clothing we are
selling
live wear what is life wear
that is ultimate everyday clothing
which makes everyone's life richer and
better
design is basic and timeless not only
for one season but can be one longer
so in our concept sustainability is
already included
sustainability is not only the concept
it is included in every step
of our product making we don't make
clothes which is not needed from
customer
that is the way we start running the
product
from the database of customers voice
we never waste our product our product
range
is mainly consists of basic products
like oxford shots t-shirts
and jeans which are not going to be
out of season so we keep selling
everything we take responsibility
on close the clothes
of the customer purchase we
collect the old code clauses
and recycle our resource reuse
this topic is main for today we are
coming back later
some example of actual
existence of our concept
black jeans case we got
customer's voice saying the dust stand
out on the black jeans so we changed
material
and now all our
black genes became dust free
we always improve our products so that
customers can
love it for a long time
literalize down case even for the most
basic products
we update the feed every year by
one millimeter also probably
no one noticed the best fit
changes by time and we want to sell
the best fit at that time to make
our clothing live longer
our new challenge is to lessen the
environmental burden so
our product making we set the two
key initiatives one
sustainable material sourcing and the
production process
2 accelerate our
recycling program the uniqlo
sustainable materials sourcing and
production
there are many projects still in
development
today we'll introduce what we have
done so far
in spring 2020
we launched the porsche using recycled
polyester
through this project we recycled
48 million pet bottles into polo shots
and reduced co2
emission about one third during the
production process of polyester chip
in fall 2020
we expanded to one of our
iconic products freeze to further
contribute to the environment
by reducing waste
the use of budget material and shields
emissions we decided to
accelerate using this this recycled
materials
in the coming seasons because
now we know that we can create
products keeping the same affordable
price
and high quality
now jeans jeans is
a key item for uniqlo lifeware
it is important for us to keep
innovating every day we have the
research and development facility
decided to genes in california
called genes innovation center
there the blue cycle project started in
2018
the project to create eco-friendly genes
with exceptional quality
let's see the movie
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in short through this project
we reduced water used by
up to 99 percent in the finishing
process
the new technology ozone washing machine
echo stone and nanobubble enabled
it this method
is applied to almost all the genes from
2020
and this is just the start we are now
developing material which reduced
the environmental bond and
rebuilding as a production process
if anything we can improve
by season by season we improve to make
the
world better thank you
hello so uh i will take over from tanaka
from now so the second initiative is the
uniqlo the project to recycle we use
every cloth we sold
so we believe so that our clothing
is northwest since 2006 we have been
collecting a beloved clothing from
customers
all over the world customers bring their
closing no longer needed to
to the stores and we are doing we use
and recycle we named
the uniqlo b means
recycle the use and finally
we are going to achieve
uh alpha reduce the environmental
impact
so it shows how to be operated
after correct correcting beloved
clothing
after collecting uh we deliver the
clothing
uh to sorting facilities and sorted into
18
categories as a donation for people in
need all over the world
those were divided into several
categories
like men's summer tops small size
or remains winter jacket large size and
kids summer bottom
small size and so on the reason why
so we sorted into 18 category is the
situation like climate
cultural background indigenous
consideration
is different in each country so we were
we are responding politely
about non-reusable clothing so we are
recycling as a automobile
sound proofing material or solid
through ethereum
next slide so
under the global partnership with unhcl
which is a
u.n organization for protecting refugees
we have been donating the refugees all
over the world
we have donated 41 million items
to 75 countries and region from 2007
as you see the map the africa is
most needed area so there are long term
internal conflict and persisted
persistent poverty program
next one the most
sustainable way we believe is to create
the circular business model
the first project is down recycling
project
a circular economy is the economic
system
minimizer waste and recycle them
as new resources aiming to
change the eco ecosystem based on
take uh it means resulted make
and waste this new economic model
is seen as ideal because it
enabled to the minimizing of
environmental impact while keeping the
economic
growth to realize this model
we needed technology development such as
improved recycling technologies and
recovery
uniqlo is developing technologies with
hardness factory and the first project
is our uh down recycle
recycling next one
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so this campaign started in
tuesday
in japan in 2019 and
collected 620 jacket
and expand it to all over the world
next one so from 2020
so uniqlo singapore have had has started
the down recycling campaign
so if you bring uniqlo down product
so to one with our store tender
voucher will be presented as a gratitude
this campaign is until the end of
january
so we count on you
next one so in 2002
uh autumn 2020 uh
using the recycle down corrected from
customers
we launched to do the uh recycle down
jacket
so it is available in singapore as well
so now hand over to tanaka sound for the
detail of
how they realize it
to happen
okay the recycling recycling
of down has two big process one
is the separation of down and phaser
from the product
and the other is to wash
separation process had been a manual
labor
that means only small amount can be
processed at one time
not efficient and not good environment
for the workers due to the light
and flying down and phasors
our partner tole developed a new
technology
the automatic separation system
we put the product in the build conveyor
and
after that automatically the machine
cuts the product in pieces and separate
separates down and phaser from other
components using wind power
in this way separation process became
50 times faster than manual labor
and enable us to produce in a big
scale enough enough to do
this in our business level
second is a washing process we cannot
leverage the detail but the
secret method of washing enabled
enable to produce the recycle down
and phaser as clean as belgium wants
problem with the scientific
scientific data these are the
photos can use the difference
same fluffy and good quality down and
feathers
now talk about the design of the product
recycle down jacket was designed by
christopher romer
and the uniqlo design team in paris
actually christoph christoph was
saying that he doesn't going to make
down
jacket anymore due to his
policy of animal welfare
however since this project
is about recycling and sakura economy
he agree and reading design
with passion here is his quote
my personal commitment and
aligned with the goal of the uniqlo
the uniqlo recycled recycled down jacket
represents unicorns and my own continued
dedication to sustainability
his design concept is sustainable at the
heart
pastel and timeless design made for all
there's an end to by an everyday
essentials that
last long
what is basket design
the feet had been perfected
so that it can be one
is on its own as a sophisticated outdoor
jacket
or layered underneath or on top of
garments
for additional worms
and designed to be genderless
key details like the soft blue neckline
further enhanced flexibility without
specific gender point of view
basic and timeless design the design was
inspired from
liner of military jacket which is not
going to be out of data
the specific onion shaped kilt was not
only for the design but has a function
to increase warmth while
reducing the stiffness
a hero altar and a comfortable liner
to perfect those two functions
carefully through the detail
the amount of down and phasers were
carefully tested and decided
not to be too less or too much
the pocket has to design
to be discrete but can be
the key element of design
the squeezed craft design is meant to
give
more warmth at the same time
easy to wear over
we broadly address the sustainability
of our product printed on the pocket
inside
versatile genders and timeless design is
sustainable
materials and the passion of design team
completely new product was born
what is crucial to this down recycling
project
is your help without all the clothing
from
customers we cannot continue
so please bring any unicorn clothing
especially uniqlo down products
to your nearest unique store
we will give them a new life for them
thank you
thank you for the insightful
presentation sharbasan and tanaka-san
we hope this session has inspired you
designers
if you are inspired by this sharing to
design new products around the team of
sustainability
the design challenge montana old clothes
new life is for you
i will now hand over to miss atika to
share on the details about the design
challenge
miss atika please
thank you gaia i hope everyone is still
with us at the moment we are off to the
final part of the webinar
as you may have learned uniqlo believes
that we can do good through clothing
by putting careful thought into
designing producing as well as selling
good clothing
we believe that we can make the world a
better place
we hope that our sharing earlier has
inspired you to rethink of certain
processes in order to reduce your
impact on the environment
um so in line with the theme zero waste
uniqlo together with
design singapore would like to take this
opportunity
to introduce a design competition where
participants are challenged
to bring new life into all clothing
so the goal here is to create one
wearable garment using all uniqlo items
with the idea of lifeware as inspiration
participants will also have the
opportunity to
pick up some of the old uniqlo items
from our office
we invite you to add your own signature
through the available pieces
using various methods techniques as well
as
any other additional materials
so the best five designs will be
showcased in our sustenancy corner at
the uniqlo processing aquarius store
in april to june this year and we'll be
featured on uniqlo's as well as dsg's
social media pages
so here are some guidelines for you to
take note of just
a brief summary at least 70
of the garment should be made from all
uniqlo items
the rest of the materials should be
generic waste or recycled items that
should not
include any local participants will also
have the opportunity
as mentioned earlier to pick up some old
uniform items from
our office or can also choose to gather
their own uniform items to supplement
the materials used
comments should be wearable as well as
transmit the message
of bringing new life into all clothing
more importantly you should not raise
any controversial topics like politics
religion or minorities
through the garment as well as the
garment should not be made with natural
fur
or feather um this is just the gist
of the guidelines that we have and you
can find more details
in the terms and conditions that we have
listed under the event
page there will also be a qr code check
later for your easy access
so with that i thank you for your
attention and wish
all interested participants all the very
best
thank you ms atika for sharing on the
design challenge okay
so we are moving into the last segment
of the day which is the q and a
before we take the first question i'd
like to introduce miss
aya hanada from uniqlo global corporate
pr social communications
who'll be joining us for the q and a
with the rest of the speakers
there's some questions coming through
the chat and if any other thoughts from
today's sharing
please feel free to keep them coming so
i think let's quickly jump into the
first question that we have
um okay so the first question that we
have is
how did you reduce waste and carbon
footprint with your fleece
jacket project
hello hello everyone this is ayahuana
from uniqlo
i'm actually working with uh silverson
in the
and about this co2 emission reducing
okay now i'm on video
okay yes on video yes yes
okay sorry okay so
um we measure every step of production
of each poly polyester
production system so from virgin oil
to it's going to make it
to polyester chip and then it's going to
be
um polyester thread yarn
and each production process we measure
how much energy we
use and then compare with the same
production process with the
using the recycle pet bottle and then
we if we compare then it's going to be
like reduced um
two-thirds and then it's going to be
like one-third of the
energy use of the when
compared with the using the virgin oil
am i making sense
okay yeah thank you okay thank you so
much
okay i'll just quickly jump to the
second question because you have a
couple of questions here
okay the next one would be what new
technologies has uniqlo introduced in
2020
and would like to plan to introduce in
the future to continuous recycling
campaign
so for um what we what technology we
introduced in 2020
was the recycled down
machine automatic so that we created
the automatic system that we take out
the down and feathers from the
old down jacket so this is
actually done by torre which is our
partner factory and they developed that
technology
so usually before and down was taken
by manual labor so it took like so long
process and uh it it was not good for
the workers environment as well
but because of this technology it became
50 times faster and then that is why we
decided to do it in a business level
and in the future technology
information is still secret so we cannot
reveal anything
sorry no it's quite interesting i'm sure
people are waiting for it yeah
and then the next question that we have
is
uh can you tell us what's your customers
feedback
on your project blue cycle is this
introduced in all your uniqlo stores
worldwide or
only on selected ones
actually this blue cycle communication
just started end of december
so this is quite new information and we
haven't
uh got any feedback yet so if you could
give us the feedback that would be great
thank you okay that's cool maybe you can
just let uh
audience also know where can they give
your feedback to him is there an email
address or something that you can
actually
drop as well so yeah yeah i'll check
no worries i don't know yeah
sure and then the next question is um
can uniqlo share how do you work on the
sustainability issue for the blue jeans
manufacturing
sorry um
can i repeat this yes yes thank you okay
so the question is uh can uniqlo share
how do you work on the sustainability
issue
for the blue jeans manufacturing
so they're asking about the blue jeans
manufacturing issue how do you actually
use sustainability for the blue jeans
so yes we are aware that there are
several
sustainability issues in the production
process
and that is why we started blue cycle
project
which um so the main
one was the use of the so we use a lot
of water
especially the when we make the jeans
um the washed you know like jeans
washing you know like the jeans which is
some
color is fading that is but because of
the washing process so we use
a lot of water and that's why we started
the
to how think about how to reduce the
water and then how to clean the water
as well so that is the basic background
of the
story of the blue cycle project and we
aware that several
issues still and we're working on it
it's like using the more sustainable
materials
or more sustainable we are thinking
about
you know like reducing the energy use or
those kind of things
okay then the next question which is
also very similar to sustainability
so it's about using a virgin oil to
manufacture polyester thread
produce uh does it pretty uh sorry uh so
the question is actually
does using virgin oil to manufacture
polyester thread
produces more carbon emission compared
to producing the threat from recycled
pet yes uh that is the
kind of same question as before but if
we measure the amount of energy
used in the production process recycled
material is much lighter
than version oil
interesting okay so the next question
that we have is also
it's about apart from down feathers
is the down jacket shell recycled
you mean the cloak yes the
other part okay
yes we are trying to make it recycle
again
but actually we don't have any solution
yet to be honest with you
um we want to recycle it too
but we haven't done it just uh right now
down and feathers
so you'll be looking into it um to see
how we can recycle
yes it's very important so while we are
at the topic about um
manufacturing so there's another
question it's actually about
does uniqlo track the social impacts of
their manufacturing processes
social impact means like um labor
problem
it can be it can be any social uh issues
that
or impacts that uh manufacturing has
yeah
um from your experience here i think
this one uh cerebral sun
is much better person to talk about just
a moment please
no worries yeah basically so yeah we are
you know
uh from the perspective of esg you know
uh employment uh uh
social and government uh governance
so you know the so we we are you know uh
measuring the social impact like for
example the supply chain you know
uh working uh condition
so this is one of uh our you know
operator industry very important
issue so we you know for example we are
you know
monitored in a process how we you know
uh improve the working condition in the
factory in each factory
and also the uh community level so we
are investing
uh some you know uh uh
action related to social issues in the
community
so in each country so we are uh
uh driving the business uh we are
you know every year so we we we also you
know
we just uh started the uh disclosure uh
this information in our website
you can see the website but how much we
uh invest in the community
so yeah so this kind of thing that we uh
measure
uh basically yeah yeah we are glad to
hear that you know uniquely actually um
years about the social impacts of
of the people yeah so uh the other
question that we have is um
because you guys manufacture right and
you guys produce a lot of um
garments and livewear so um can we just
find out how does uniqlo actually find
out what the customer actually wants
like for example how does uniqlo knows
that they want dust free jeans for
instance yeah
so um we
click the customer voice so we have a
big customer center and then
each day we have a lot of people call
and also um we have some kind of web
format that a customer can
put their comments on it and also we
check closely with the comments on the
e-commerce product page we have a lot of
good
information in the comment page so
there's a big department in our company
and they analyze all that data including
the sns or
more public data as well and then they
they report to each department what is
the customers
saying right now uh including the
product
product team or design team
and also marketing team and also us the
sustainability related
team as well so they are they're playing
the big role
in our product making
okay the next question would be
very similar but it's about whether
uniqlo is actually
implementing the take back scheme how is
the reuse or recycling practices
actually done in uniqlo mean that
clothing yes how are you doing correct
so do you reuse or recycle
what are the practices that uniqlo has
actually currently
okay i think this is shelbasang
um thank you for the question so you
know
so as i explained in the presentation
so after you know uh customer uh
you know brought our clothing then we
you know
uh insult it into 18 categories
for this uh be used then so
we you know uh divided uh
you know commands talks and small
site as needed in the you know uh
for example refugee camp we you know
got requests from unhcr which is a u.n
organization for refugees
then you know it depending on their
needs
we prepare the you know use of
clothing for the closing
so this is you know a used part and the
recycle part
as uh you know uh this is unreusable
clothing everything we at 100 percent we
recycled
material or sometimes you know the uh
burning other you know energy
this is the two way we are doing so
reuse and recycle
does it make sense yeah it's quite
interesting to find out that it's
just a long process for the recycling
and really yeah
yeah yeah yeah yep and then uh well we
are at it right so uh
what are some challenges that you have
when communicating sustainability
initiative to customers
and are you is it possible to share one
example that you and your team have
encountered
and overcome is it anything
i think why is the unique law as a
customer
you know action we you know
this you know sustainability is not for
from our side we need to get to
uh you know cooperation from
you know customer and you know ngo
and other partners so we try to engage
every you know stakeholder
this is our fundamental thinking so
uniqlo is the
best action for us to
get the customers participation we
believe
that makes sense yeah do you have any
example that you like to share
so this is not only the communication
problem but also
um yes it's a very difficult part
executing the sustainability or
recycling project
so when we start down recycling project
honestly the hardest thing was
collecting down
and yes we did a lot of communication
using owns media
and then also like we did in pr
and a lot of media um
was really excited about it and then
we got a lot of publicity but
um it was not enough for us to
the actual collection was not enough for
us to um i mean
start production for the next season's
down
so this is not only for us
but also all the recycling project in
the world but the most
difficult thing is to get the support
from customers
and then ask them to recycle
because if there is nothing uh people
don't
support we cannot make any product out
of it
so it's also same as pet bottle
recycling or some
other recycling it is very hard so
please respec as please recycle
all everything you can
sorry sorry one more thing
it came out one you know example so now
so in japan so we are doing school
outreach programs
so we our employee
visited school in japan then they
you know uh took some uh
take some you know uh lesson
so in the reason so uh you know
so they will uh explain about
the re-uniqlo program then you know
after that
so the student will uh participate
in the in a recycling program in in
their you know school
so this is one you know education
program but uh
so this is good to you know uh you know
engagement for
uh community so school is a very big
community so through this community so
you know
children and their parents can
understand
our you know program through this you
know
uh education program this is one example
it's we it's important to do our part as
an individual as well to recycle and
reuse
yeah to help the community as well yes
and
can i can i still this is a big problem
definitely so what is the hard part of
communication is that
we always struggle with the
communicate what to communicate so one
part is that we count on consumer
customers good heart and we communic
so once we can communicate about what is
good about recycling
and then on the other hand we have some
kind of coupon
incentive for consumers to um
you know like don't donate the clothes
and uh
incentive or the good heart which is the
most uh
good uh working information for
consumers we don't know it's just
super hard for us to do that still
struggling
yeah so well yeah the topic of recycling
right so
um that's like you guys collect i mean
recycle your materials and etc what
about button and zips do you guys also
recycle or reuse
them we haven't actually
but there's a project and that we cannot
talk about it sorry
no but at least there's something that
you know has been put and taught into
yeah
yes we have discussed it yes so um
well um we are so we are quickly
approaching to the end of the q a
session we can take one last question
um so this question is about as fast
fashion
how do you get the quantity of stock
required and how are
any extra stock being handled afterwards
just a moment just a moment please no
worries
just give us some time to um for the
speakers to
to answer this question so this will
answered by tanaka and he will answer in
japanese so
i will translate sorry in japanese
so firstly we don't make too much
we control the amount of production
so basically we plan um
plan to set make what we sell
that's all
so we um we plan
we plan what we actually selling and
what we produce what we're selling
and then we actually sell the amounts
that we planned
management
and that is all all the part of our
sustainability
project including the total supply chain
process
and the demand planning
and we don't waste anything we sell
everything to the end
is we answer your question yeah it's
quite um encouraging to know that you
know unique is taking all these steps
towards
sustainability agenda and i also like to
take this opportunity to thank our
panelists for the engaging conversation
so
i hope you enjoyed today's webinar we
would like to thank you for joining us
this afternoon
should you revisit should you revisit
today's discussion
a summary of the key notes will be
shared with you via email
along with the relevant links on how you
reach out to the speakers
please help us with the post event
survey which should be appearing on your
screen
right now
and if you like to raise that for the
design challenge
just scan the qr code that you see on
this the screen
which is on the right yeah and also
thank you sharbasan tanaka-san
hanaka-san and attica for the wonderful
sharing today
and to all attendees we hope you found
the session inspiring and meaningful
we hope to see you at our subsequent
events and do sign up for the design
challenge
thank you and see you soon
you